it's a tough story out of minnesota the
district attorney handling the dante
wright case says we may learn today
if the officer who shot him will be
charged this comes after a third night
of protest in brooklyn center minnesota
that's the city where dante wright died
and also other demonstrations in
philadelphia chicago and dallas
omar villafranca is in brooklyn center
where police say
officer kim potter meant to reach for
her taser
before shooting and killing dante wright
omar good morning to you
good morning the national guard is still
here behind me looking over the scene
after another
night of protest despite a curfew pepper
spray and of course flash bangs were
used to disperse the crowd and there
were around 60 arrests
yesterday the chief of police and
officer kim potter both resigned
but some people say that potter should
have been fired
i never imagined this is what was going
to happen i just thought maybe he was
being arrested
kate wright dante's mother said she was
on the phone with the woman who was in
the car with her son
moments after the shooting and it was on
a facetime
and she said she was crying and
screaming and she said that they shot
him
and she pointed the phone towards the
driver's seat and my son was laying
there
unresponsive that was the last time that
i seen my son
police say dante wright had been pulled
over for an expired vehicle attack
they say officers tried to arrest him
when they learned of an
outstanding warrant and that he resisted
police say
officer kim potter who had been training
a new officer
thought she reached for her taser
but she fired a gun instead officer
potter was a 26-year veteran of the
police force
along with police chief tim gannon
potter offered her resignation tuesday
saying in a letter she believes it is in
the best interest of the community
the department and my fellow officers if
i resign immediately
brooklyn center mayor mike elliott you
know i'm hoping that
this will help bring some calm to
to the community although you know i
think ultimately people want justice
why was she allowed to resign and why
didn't you fire her instead
we were going through our own processes
to make sure that
we had all of the documentation in order
in order to be able to do that
dante right life matters
in a show of solidarity wright's family
met tuesday with the family of george
floyd
just outside the courthouse where the
murder trial of former officer derek
shovin is being held
we're here and we will fight for justice
for this family just like we're fighting
for our brother
at that press conference yesterday i
also asked since potter resigned and was
not fired would she
still get her pension and able be able
to get another job in law enforcement
the mayor and the acting police chief
could not answer that question
the mayor also was asking the case to be
reassigned to the state attorney general
but the state ag says
he feels confident the washington county
d.a can handle this case
gail that's a very good question you
asked omar because a lot of people are
wondering will she now be able to get
another job and that's a problem for
many thank you very much